tu sais faire des imitations ici qu'à
vous imitez qui moi je suis pas très bon
imitateur un petit truc même pourri
franchement je suis un peu je fais
christophe maé vite fait coisy
schaffhouse pas preneur c'est moi je
rêvais d'amour rien n'est plus le coeur
[Musique]
moi je fais jean-marie le pen ça il le
fait hyper bien je le fais trop bien
saisi
[Rires]
jean-marie le pen entre somail lopez et
régis laspalès un chien quelle crise
actuelle est pas mal mais ça khourmatou
fête géniale idée non johnny c'est white
asie ok ça lui ces données la fouine
fait quoi eh bien oui j'arrive chez le
maire fait quoi jean michel mère de
céline dion à peu près je suis bien
contente d'être avec vous un pouvoir
jaser pas vraiment ça qu'il s'est fait
beaucoup de peine
vous tirez vous faites quoi bonsoir
madame au chômage elle bouge toi
monsieur avait fait des effets des
privés bonsoir bonsoir cyril hanouna
alors vous fait faire des imitations
tout le monde
est-ce que vous avez honte de vous un
petit peu quand même s'il faut préciser
que ce qui s'est passé
homer simpson allées chaudes la moulette
ce soit
[Applaudissements]
juste il change pas de boire gilles lui
adresser les châles kemp été gêné une
soirée en deux ça vous fait quoi elle ça
bref toujours le même c'est un mélange
de maïté maître gims asie malaisie alors
on mesure ce soir nous allons manger une
barquette de frites avec de la soupe au
pouvoir voilà tout simplement et c'est
très bien son mari l'opinion
[Musique]